Speaker 1: Let's hear from people in the
audience. After some time away from live
calls, let's start today with Harry from
Columbus, Ohio. Harry, welcome. How are you?
Speaker 3: Hey, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can hear you beautifully, Harry.
Speaker 3: First and foremost, a very
happy and healthy paternity to you.
Thank you. Congratulations.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
Speaker 3: Sir. I want to get quickly. Yes? I was
at a wedding over the weekend and one of my wife's
relatives asked me a question. They know I'm
relatively politically minded. I said to me after
a couple of drinks, they said, Harry, do you know
Dave Ramsey? And I am not very familiar with Dave
Ramsey. I mean, I don't have a lot of assets
personally. I have a41k, but that's about it.
And he was like, okay. So Dave Ramsey says
said very, very good, straightforward advice.
I asked him, Why do you like Dave Ramsey? It was
very straightforward advice. Like, for example,
Dave Ramsey says, if you are paying off
your mortgage, you shouldn't buy a BMW.
And that's what he said to me. I was, you know, a
bit perplexed at first. I was like, okay, there's
multiple reasons why you may or may not want to
buy a BMW, and I'm sure a mortgage is one of them.
But just what is the point of, you know, Dave
Ramsey give giving people these platitudes like,
I will understand.
Speaker 1: You. You've got
to keep it simple, though. Here's the whole thing.
Personal finance is simple, but people think it's
complicated. So when Dave Ramsey then simplifies
it for you, people go, This is great stuff because
it's so simple. But the things Dave Ramsey
says aren't always true. And he's a right wing
religious ideologue who uses supposedly simple
financial advice to actually just espouse right
wing political beliefs. I mean, he's anti-vax,
anti-mask. He's he's anti-regulation, you know,
all these different things. So my my take is
sometimes Dave Ramsey says uncontroversial,
true things, but you can get those same things
from a handful of books. In fact, I have a page
on my website David Pakman dot com slash finance
where I give you ten or 12 books where if you read
them, you don't need to waste any time listening
to Dave Ramsey because everything you need to know
about personal finance is in those 10 to 12 books.
And quite frankly, you could probably read three
of them and get most of what you need just to take
the mortgage example. There are lots of people,
okay, now I know this is not everybody,
but there is there's plenty of people who,
in a low interest rate environment would say, hey,
you know what, I could pay cash for this house,
but I want to get a 2.8% mortgage. It's not
available anymore. Okay. But a year and a half,
you could do this. I'm going to save my cash, get
a 2.8% mortgage, invest the rest, which over time
in the market should make me 7%. And I'm going to
get myself a BMW and it could be a completely sane
and rational financial decision. So I get that
the ideas are meant to apply to large swaths
of people, but almost nothing, Dave Ramsey says,
really applies to everybody. So I just I'm not a
fan. It's not it's not for me, Doug, you know?
Speaker 3: Yeah, no, I appreciate that. I was
thinking about the BMW thing specifically and I'm
thinking, you know what, if you're 30 years old,
you just got into a mortgage. But you
know, you really wanted a BMW since you
were 12 years old. What are you supposed to
do? Dave Ramsey says wait till you're 60.
Speaker 1: Right. And this is why
a lot of the a lot of the other
financial writers that I follow, you know, people
like Ramit Sethi, Enigma, Julie and others, you've
got to balance things and not just put everything
off forever because because to a certain degree,
there is a reason that you are trying to
have a strong financial position. You know,
and by and by the way, if you lease a vehicle,
you might lease a vehicle through a business,
which makes it a total tax deduction. And
you might have a mortgage. And it doesn't
mean that leasing a BMW is irresponsible. And
I just don't know. It's oversimplification
and guru fixation, and I'm not a big fan of it.
Speaker 3: I really appreciate you pointing out
the whole way that Dave Ramsey puts
a right wing spin on things that are
unrelated to personal finance. Right. I really
wanted to hear you flesh that out for me. I
appreciate you taking my call. And again. Happy
paternity. Happy fatherhood. Thank you so much.
Speaker 1: Thank you very much. Very much.
Appreciate the call. I appreciate the opportunity.